[Music]
hey guys welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing albus dumbledore severus
snape
and an arrangement they made before the
events of the 31st of october
1981 in the deathly hallows harry
witnesses an old interaction between
dumbledore and snape
that would ultimately influence his
opinion of both men
it was perhaps one of the most important
interactions to have ever occurred
as it pertained to the potter family the
prophecy and the night that james and
lily potter
were murdered this night however also
marked the end of the first wizarding
war
as lord voldemort was simultaneously
defeated by infant harry
thanks to his mother's sacrificial
protection though this night was tragic
it was the end of an era and it brought
peace back to the wizarding community
at least for a time lord voldemort
traveled there that night
intent on killing baby harry because of
sibyl trilogy's prophecy
the one with the power to vanquish the
dark lord approaches born to those who
have thrived to fight him
born as the seventh month dies and the
dark lord will mark him as his equal
but he will have power the dark lord
knows not and either must die at the
hand of the other
for neither can live while the other
survives the one with the power to
vanquish the dark lord
will be born as the seventh month dies
severus snape who was a death eater at
the time
quickly found out about the prophecy as
he was infatuated with lily
harry's mother he knew almost
immediately that he would need to act
his loyalties lay with the death eaters
but his love for lily was larger than
his devotion to their cause
and though snape was death eater he
wasn't in it for the same reasons as
some of the others
he wasn't hell-bent on power he was just
lost confused
and felt that he had nowhere else to go
the result of the abuse inflicted upon
him in his formative years
additionally snape was massively
magically talented and found praise for
this in the ranks of the death eaters
he felt that he was appreciated by them
nonetheless
when snape became aware of the fact that
the potters were in danger he knew that
he would have to do something
how could he ensure that lily potter
stays safe with nowhere else to go
snape turns to his enemy albus
dumbledore
the adult snape was panting turning on
the spot his wand gripped tightly in his
hand
waiting for something or for someone
then a blinding
jagged jet of white light flew through
the air well
severus what message does lord voldemort
have for me
no no message i'm here on my own account
snape was ringing his hands he looked a
little mad with his straggling black
hair flying around him
i i come with a warning no a request
please what request could a death eater
make of me
the the prophecy the prediction trelawny
uh yes sir dumbledore how much did you
relate to lord voldemort
everything everything i heard said snape
that is why
it is for that reason he thinks it means
lily heavens
the prophecy did not refer to a woman
said dumbledore
it spoke of a boy born at the end of
july you know what i mean
he thinks it means her son he's going to
hunt her down kill them all
if she means so much to you said
dumbledore surely the
voldemort will spare her could you not
ask for mercy for the mother
in exchange for the son i have i have
asked him
you disgust me said dumbledore and harry
had never heard so much contempt in his
voice
snape seemed to shrink a little you do
not care then
about the deaths of her husband and
child they can die
as long as you have what you want snape
said nothing but merely looked up at
dumbledore
hide them all then he quote keep it them
safe please and what will you give me in
return
severus in in return snape gate to
dumbledore
and harry expected him to protest but
after a long moment he said
anything one thing that stuck out to me
in this passage is that dumbledore asked
snape for something in exchange
to keep the plotters safe dumbledore is
an ally of the potter family
so why would he need further incentive
to help snape out and keep them alive
the reason for this is that dumbledore
didn't trust snape he was unsure of what
his motivations truly were
however he did recognize that snape was
in a state of desperation
and knew that he would do anything to
make sure that lily potter would survive
in this scene dumbledore is toying with
snape a little bit
and assessing him he's doing this
because snape a former student turned
death eater
has a dubious past if dumbledore were to
simply acquiescently accept snape's
request
with no questions asked firstly he would
look weak
as he has no reason to appease the
requests of an enemy secondly
dumbledore needed to gauge the
authenticity of snape's request
and by making a demand of snape it
quickly became clear that this was truly
snape's last resort
and that he was genuine at the point at
which snape reaches extreme desperation
dumbledore asserts his position of power
and agrees to help snape
knowing that from that point onward he
had a new ally
and that's it for this video if you have
any questions leave them down in the
comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry
you